we have a david pakman show subreddit
which has nearly 11,000 subscribers from
our audience now you can find it at
david pakman.com slash read it people
ask me David why don't you give us the
actual reddit address because it's very
long it's reddit.com slash are slash the
david pakman show it's much easier to
just say david pakman.com slash read it
i got a couple emails last week people
saying david you're trying to get phony
traffic to your website by using a
redirect no I'm not
it's just easier to say david pakman.com
slash reddit it will redirect you to our
subreddit a couple of notable posts and
discussions from the last couple of days
that i want to point out to you once
again another post saying I really want
Dave to debate Candace I don't know if
that debate is ever going to happen a
lot of you may remember that at one
point it seemed as though Kyle : ski and
I were going to do a two-on-two debate
with conservative people I'm lacking in
the right words here conservative
individuals Candace Owens and Charlie
Kirk at politican 2018 back in October
in Los Angeles it turns out that I guess
they were never really doing it or at
least Candace was not and then it looked
as though I was told by a third party
that was organizing a debate that
Candace Owens had agreed in principle to
debate me and we were just finalizing
topics and the dates tentatively one of
those dates was March 18th as you might
know looking at a calendar March 18th
has long come and gone and it doesn't
seem at this point that there's any
reasonable opportunity for me to debate
Candace Owens it doesn't seem that she
wants to do it to be clear it's not me
that is holding it up it is Candace and
that invitation remains open
also from the david pakman show
subreddit a post pointing out that there
is a dave rubin event in Rocklin
California on June 22nd and a couple of
people in the comments said that they
are planning to go and what should they
ask related to the David Pakman show so
let us tell you right now because you
might remember dave rubin recently said
during a public event when asked about
interviewing me
that he is not against it in principle
but that I've lied about him many times
he said pac-man has lied about me a
bunch of times and I've asked for and
others have been asking for what those
lies were so if you go to a Dave Rubin
event event and you get the opportunity
to ask a question a question that will
almost definitely get the video clip on
the show is asking Dave Rubin what
specific lies did David Pakman tell
about you that would be a really great
question to ask Dave Rubin another great
question for dave rubin did you watch
and if so what did you think of david
pakman z' joe rogan appearance another
question would be David Pakman has said
he would like to talk to you publicly
about the rift between the two of you
are you willing to do that what
preconditions would you need like if
Dave if David Pakman was willing to not
mention the phrase marketplace of ideas
for example would you would that be a
reasonable precondition for you to agree
to a conversation with David Pakman do
you think you and David Pakman will ever
reconcile your relationship would be an
interesting question for dave rubin and
i think most people in our audience who
are aware of what's going on can
probably come up on their own with other
interesting and relevant questions for
dave rubin at his events video of which
would almost be guaranteed to make it
onto the program presuming the audio and
video quality as good please no vertical
recording record horizontally horizontal
recording much more likely to make it
onto the program these and many other
interesting conversations including
others about policy it's not all about
gossip within the online media community
happening with almost 11,000 of our
viewers and listeners daily on the david
pakman show subreddit david pakman.com
slash our EDD IT